you know I think it's so interesting
about content nowadays is that like
we've gone through so many decades of a
certain type of narrative from like
female dominated you know whether it be
talk shows or this kind of right so it's
like these Echo chambers that have been
created which
um goes into women's empowerment while
also kind of like a subtle Diss and shot
at man like Menace trash type [__] but
see the difference today is is that now
people are incentivized to be truthful
so I think now that we have Tick Tock
and IG reels and all of these things and
you have these people just on screen
just saying whatever it is that they
want to say so now we get more of an
insight into actual human behavior
versus the construction of media over
the past several decades so that's why
so many people are looking at the
content like what and you get so many
dudes that are just like oh women are
not all sugar spice and everything nice
they can be just as violent as me well
not just as violent but you know I like
they have the aptitude I just appreciate
Pearl that you're so willing to to say
these things mm-hmm meaning to like
actually call it the thing I love is
women tend to be a lot more agreeable
and as soon as someone says and you know
men talk [__] but as soon as a woman on
your panel says some asinine you
automatically and I'm like what is she
gonna do it when is she gonna call her
up boom right away
I just want to get my popcorn I'm like
yes right away she calls it out but you
do it in a tactful way where even if
people are mad at you they they usually
they take it pretty well on your show at
least you'd be surprised they've gotten
upset at you but if it was listen if it
was a threats
not on your panel probably in your DM
right no no it'll be like like basically
what'll happen is girl come on the Pod
say some wild but then it gets clipped
goes viral I mean I don't know what you
thought was gonna happen and and so like
this one girl
um this guy on the panel wasn't even me
it was like everyone say their body
count three two one and his whole point
was that none of the girls were gonna
say it this girl said it okay now it was
like it was like four five but she's
Indian or something in her community
yeah
anyways my point she wanted me to take
the stream down and I was like no I paid
a producer it's like you go through all
this work to get the panel together she
threatened me with like the Indian Mafia
I don't know
very intimidating yeah because you know
is where I live because it's like the
podcast so it's like yeah and then she
was just gonna wait with her Matthew
they never did it though I just said do
it I didn't even know it was an Indian
Mafia I didn't know either
everybody's got a mafia a little curry
truck that shows up oh [__] Are You
Pearl my friend was actually on like a
huge Indian skin
with social security cards in America
it was like this huge like scam where
they were in Texas and like
um
interacting with immigrants who had just
gotten their green cards and their
social security number and they would
steal them and like bankrupt them
basically and then they went on the run
and they're still looking for them in
India I think Indians are pretty cool
though
over overall they're overall they've
been pretty nice they support I'm gonna
go back to what you said though so you
are right that people are being more
open
um and speaking freely but the other
issue is that because there's
such a push to become famous a lot of
people push very extreme ideas too and
that's become a very problematic thing I
think in society is because you're now
hearing all these extreme ideas which
are not being mainstreamed across
platforms and causes a lot of hate
across the board I mean Center Center
ideas everybody can somewhat understand
you know but when you go to the extremes
then it causes just so much [__] in the
world well there's also a lot of
horseshit too there's honesty but
there's also a lot of horseshit but I
guess every the thing is is we want a
free Society but we've gone so free to
the point where we I think people don't
want to accept and you talk about this
Pearl that
as humans we have certain biological
order there's a certain way that things
go
and that is the best way for a society
to run so that's it's a very broad
statement what I mean by that is men
tend to be territorial men should be
masculine they should be fit they should
provide it there are certain things that
we were built to do certain things that
women are better at and should do
doesn't mean women need to be in the
kitchen doesn't mean they can't have a
job
but I think and this is again things
that plenty of people have spoken about
when and I love when when Tate said this
and he said when uh when you're in a
country when you're living in a country
that's third world and doesn't have much
in the sense of in the uh
in the way of resources people will go
back to their natural ways
and now that we have it so cushy in
America everyone's doing this and doing
that and people want to be cheetahs they
uh they identify as Dolphins you can do
whatever your heart desires but
naturally there's always going to be a
certain order of things and
our brains always are always gonna gonna
go that way when it's all said and done
we're trying to change things that's not
going to work uh so next question
why do you think
women like men who've been with a lot of
other women or who are around many women
why do you think that's so attractive to
them even though they say it's not it
always is I mean I think most girls
don't really want to be telling a guy
what to do and instructing him yeah so I
think it's like when a guy knows what
he's doing it's just most girls would
prefer that
um
and you know we like we like a smooth
talker and how does a smooth talker get
smooth practice
makes Fair points
it's just so interesting how the
Opposites and this is what goes into my
primal thing is like women have
pre-selection they want what they want a
guy who's liked by other women the
opposite is usually true for men like
sure we like a girl that other men find
attractive but to a point you know what
I'm saying like if every guy is making
some nasty comments
I don't know if I know that she's with
20 other dudes in in the same uh
Friendship Circle um that's the same
thing or one like huh or one or even
yeah or even one dude I'm dude I'm super
old school man like I'm not crazy I'm
not gonna I wouldn't relate to a verse
at this point but I am very traditional
in the sense where if there's a high I'm
out
ain't happening for something casual I
couldn't care less though
uh here's another good one can men be
vulnerable with women
what's your tick
um they can they certainly can and
nothing's stopping them
um but it just depends what outcome you
want and I think a lot of times men are
vulnerable with their women and they
think that their women will look at them
the same and often they don't at least
that's what the men have said I
personally when I first started
listening to Red Pill content I was like
oh yeah you talk to women like
[Music]
and then I thought about I thought about
it long and hard and I'm like do you
want a guy that's crying all the time no
doing a guy that's always constantly
telling me how how he feels no did it
annoy me when my ex would always be
telling me how he felt yes and so it's
like we don't even know what we want
you I don't know you have to you're
doing God's work because you have this
logic that I just don't see very often
it's just the triggering happens right
away and people shut down so I'm just
saying so Rolo tomasi if do you know you
ever heard of roller tomasi have you
okay so rule tamasi is kind of what's
coin the king of the red pill or the the
pioneer of the red pill red pill is I uh
essentially it's a very controversial
group of people and I agree with most of
what they say
um I'm not uh a dating podcast
specifically but I would definitely
consider myself a red pill to a degree
and we'll go deeper into that but
he has written a series of books called
the rational mail their International
best best-selling books I would
encourage as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible